welcome to the beijing alps
as you can see and as you'll know if
you've been watching the olympics
there's not much snow
traditionally rather an important
element for winter games
beijing is incredibly dry it gets less
annual snowfall than london so all the
snow at the games is artificial
much of it came from the water in this
reservoir called baijobao
this whole area is as dry as dust but
this reservoir is a frozen oasis in the
mountain desert and the waters
underneath this ice are used to supply
beijing because it has very little but
recently they've been diverted to create
snow for the winter olympics because
otherwise they'd have none
holding a winter olympics in a place
where it doesn't snow using energy
intensive machines like this have led
some to question the event's green
credentials these are the most
unsustainable games ever held because
there's so much
at cost from the water issues to the
water availability and even
to the nato destruction of the local
nato reserve
others have complained about the big air
site in downtown beijing saying it looks
dystopian
that's probably unfair this was once a
huge polluting steelworks now repurposed
into a cleaner residential and
commercial site
the sort of development that would be
applauded in other cities
but the international olympic committee
does understand the impression that bear
mountains give viewers obviously you
know uh we're in a winter sport and
we have to acknowledge that what you see
on the screen
might be disturbing for some people
um but the reality is that the chinese
are actually
doing and delivering this winter sport
with sustainability in mind in
everything they have done so from really
building the venues or even repurposing
five venues from 2008
to using for the first time ever 100
renewable energy
to using low carbon mobility
climate change means beijing won't be
the last winter olympic city to rely on
fake snow
snow from a reservoir rather than the
sky
may become the new normal tom cheshire
sky news beijing